اه
[موسيقى]
تحدث عن رد شخص واحد على
مطلق النار النشط مما يعني أن
ضابط الشرطة في الحرم الجامعي لا
ينتظر أي شخص ليأتي في
أوقات الوالد الأساسي وهذا
ما أريد سماعه أعني أن هناك  لا يوجد وقت
للتفاوض مع مطلق النار النشط أو
القاتل النشط في مدارسنا ، ليس
هناك وقت
للتحدث معهم.
هذا البلد
من حيث التأخير في إنقاذ حياة الأطفال أمر
غير مقبول نحتاج
إلى تحسينه كمجتمع لإنفاذ القانون
وقد يكون
هذا موقفًا مخيفًا هذا ليس
وضعًا مريحًا لأي شخص ولكن
ما هو أكثر ترويعًا من هؤلاء  يجب على التدريبات
أن تدفن طفلًا
يبلغ من العمر ستة أعوام وسبع أعوام أو يبلغ من العمر ثماني سنوات يموت ، وهذا
أمر مخيف بالنسبة لي ، هذه التدريبات مدهشة
نعم إنها واقعية ومخيفة ولكنها
مطلوبة في هذا المجتمع.
ou